[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money and your family and your
relationships and all the things that
matter to you i'm george campbell ramsey
personality joined this hour by my good
friend and ramsay personality christy
wright and it's a free call today triple
eight eight two five five two two five
don't be shy pick up the phone it's not
just for texts and apps it actually
makes phone calls christy did you know
with your voice that's amazing yes and i
just saw your your media hit that you
did uh on fox business talking about
taking back your tech yeah and taking
back your life when it comes to
technology that's right but uh you know
you got to pick up your phone to call
these days unless you have a landline
well it's so great because so often i
feel like people feel stuck in life they
feel frustrated with challenges they're
facing or a decision they have to make
and that is exactly the heart behind
this show we want to help you give you
advice when you're at that fork in the
road you've got a few options you're not
sure which option is the best and of
course we're known for money but um you
know whether it's a business question or
a question about how to have more time
how to manage your time uh relationships
whatever we're here for you so yeah pick
up your phone call maybe you're sitting
in traffic give us a call if things get
slow i have a lot of questions for you
christy i struggle i struggle with this
i am glued to the tech
my wife is trying to help so she'll be
appreciative of that i gave you a hard
time was it last week when we did game
plan oh we hit all of us after we get
off stage are like you know getting some
water taking a minute and george here
he's on youtube i'm jumping in the live
stream hey guys hey guys i just love it
i feel like i'm missing out on the party
be with your people what are you um
on the disc are you like really high eye
for like relationships people i'm about
a mid i and then real high s and then c
follows that so i care deeply and i love
the details so it's a very neurotic
personality type to have very stressful
anxiety inducing uh but hey it makes me
a great friend there you go there you go
so we are taking your calls folks and
we're going to kick it off with paul in
atlanta georgia paul welcome to the
ramsey show
hey gang thank you for having me how's
everyone doing we are doing great how
can we help awesome awesome well i'm
gonna i'm gonna throw the situation up
there and uh i'll catch you me and my
wife are starting to hit uh starting at
the next drive we just got married first
child's on the way uh we just found out
we're five weeks along congrats
thank you thank you we have 175k left on
our current home she moved in with me
she has about 17 000 all left on the car
i'm going to pay off between the two of
us we got about
and eighty thousand dollars cash
seven hundred thousand in savings just
just north of seven hundred
savings not retirement
with retirement you know okay
that's different i was like man you've
just been stockpiling
yeah yeah so yeah um you know so we got
we got those six months and all
here's the thing
we we are now looking to move just a
little north of us there's a home that
we're having built we only have to put
5000 on it and we can walk away from
that if we want to
it's 550 000 we could do 150 000 down
payment
but we estimate with uh to get down to
400k we're trying to figure out if it's
the right move to us
my mortgage goes from 1000 to 2500. she
would like to quit work for at least a
year
at least and i'm getting the perception
that this might be a permanent
retirement
um to be with our child which i'm all
for so she wants to stay at home if you
guys do this move
she wants to stay on period okay with
the child with the child we were having
a new one
on our wedding day oh no less yeah and
um
so what's your take home pay after that
if you're down to one income what's that
not let's go let's go with 90 000. i can
make just a little more than 100 but
like oh the year before it was 90 and i
like i like saying that number okay so
90 and what's your take home
uh the take home whatever after
okay so what we would recommend here is
for that that mortgage payment on a
15-year fix is that the numbers that you
were laying out or was that on a 30-year
mortgage no we were doing it and that's
what that's the other thing we were
doing a 30 year old that's 2.99 yeah so
it's 2500 bucks and that is on the 30
year
yeah that's on the 30 year exactly yeah
just just looking at these numbers it
just feels like a lot of house for where
you guys are at right now and you said
that she's got seventeen thousand
dollars on this car loan
yeah we're i'm gonna pay that off and so
about 180 we have in cash will go down
to uh 160 will change
yeah i mean you guys have a you have a
good down payment but based on the house
that you guys are wanting and the take
home pay with you going to one income
correct we'll be home poor that's how i
feel exactly yeah i mean you have the
right that's a wonderful person so just
before we even go any further than that
i'm just i don't think she sees it the
way i see it um well i want you guys on
the same page you must only have 300 at
the end of every month to
go enjoy life with which we could
uh what would it look like uh paul to
have does she work right now
she does she's got a good job what does
she make
uh she does around 65.
okay
george is over here with his notepad
running some numbers i'm not doing the
mental math that this would work but
what would a conversation be possible
where you say something like hey um i
know you want to stay home for a year
you may want to stay home longer than
that what if we stay put to see if you
want to stay home and if you want to
move then it's going to look like some
type of sacrifice either a child care or
you working from home or you're going
back to work in order to your point paul
because it's going to be so tight it's
like it's kind of an either or situation
in this season if if you get a raise or
you guys make more money in the future
she may be able to stay home business
owner so there's no raise other than my
um there you go you got to give yourself
the rest
i'd love to give myself the next step
you know go to the boss but i am the
boss so there you go
it might just be a conversation of which
do you want more right now do you want
to move or do you want to stay home
because at some point we might be able
to do both but right now we kind of have
to choose i don't know
i completely and we put together a game
power i threw one down because of the
700 we haven't combined i have a little
bit more and i think we look at it as
our money yeah but i i had added in a
little bit more than 70 percent of the
of that quote combined um savings or
retirement funding well i don't want you
touching the retirement
well you know like in 10 years we could
just take a chunk of that and pay off it
would be down to 300 000. well i don't
think i don't want you ever touching
this retirement money until you were
actually retired
exactly so i think i mean you guys
you've got a good head on your shoulders
here i think what this is gonna take is
some patience and you might need to say
hey we're either gonna downgrade a house
and not get a 550 000 house right now or
we're gonna be patient for a year let
her continue to work so that you can
stack up some extra cash because what
i'm seeing here is you need a mortgage
payment that's gonna be about being born
next year or or like a year because
that's what she really wants to be there
on with the child i'm all for it yeah
for the baby's health first and foremost
and then the answer is
i'm all for it then that answers your
question and the reality is if she stays
home for a year and y'all stay in this
house which you can more than afford it
sounds like then she's got the option to
do that and if you move to a big house
then you're taking that option away for
her ability to stay home year two three
and so on i think from what i'm hearing
from you it sounds like your values and
her values are for her to stay home and
the best way to put you in that position
to be able to live from your values stay
home with this new baby which y'all are
so excited about is to stay in this
house which y'all can afford i think you
i think you know the answer paul i think
you knew when you called you may just
needed us to to validate it we've been
balanced back and forth and i'm the jerk
because for the last four months i go
i'm all in and then i'm out yeah
i know we shouldn't do that
i'm vacillating and that's my problem
for sure paul here's the thing don't let
emotions take over here we gotta stick
to the math and you're doing the math
and i love that but it's going to take
some patience
and let the baby come and we'll have a
great time with that but be patient
maybe a year from now you can be looking
to get in that house
[Music]
let's go
still on baby step number one
how did you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number give us a call i'm george
campbell joined by christy wright and
this is the ramsey show and we are
headed to springfield illinois to chat
with david david welcome to the ramsay
show
hey thank you how you guys doing great
how are you
i'm doing i'm doing pretty well
what's your question
so uh earlier this year i started a lawn
care and landscape company after you
know a few years in industry
um
now this make this question may have
asked been asked before um
but
like i said it's our first year and
we're kind of wondering what to put away
for
you know maintenance or business savings
and
mainly what we should be paying
ourselves if it's like a percentage that
you recommend or if it kind of varies
per person per industry
um right now we're paying ourselves
about 50
of everything that we're making from the
from the company
yeah you know david i've got a few
follow-up questions because while in
general uh the money flows the same
regardless of the size of your business
sometimes it does need to get more
sophisticated the bigger the business is
so if you're running like a side gig and
it's just you it can it's a pretty
simple formula of
saving for taxes setting aside that 25
saving for emergencies three to six
months of business expenses um you know
obviously all your expenses of cost of
goods if you've got a product or um
overhead you know in either situation
and then you pay yourself out of the
profit that's left over
it sounds like your business might be a
little bit bigger than that do you have
team members what are we talking with
like top line revenue and stuff
no it's it's just me okay um
my wife um is a stay-at-home mom so it's
just me and for our first year we're
doing pretty well we're on our we're
like halfway to our goal of of being
able to go full time because right now i
have a another part-time job oh this is
a side business then okay
yeah but eventually we're going to have
the goal you know eventually we're going
to be moving into full time possibly
next year then within the next few years
we'll probably be hiring some employees
cool when did you start this business
uh march of this year okay cool so i'll
give you kind of a high level um answer
and then
this will get you started on the right
track but there's a couple other things
i want you to consider
you're going to need to
set aside there's there's a few
different ways that you allocate the
money you want to set aside 25 percent
for taxes so this is something that you
you set aside on the front end you don't
want that sneaking up on you you don't
want the irs after you and so go ahead
and plan in advance for taxes
the other thing you set aside money for
um would be business expenses this is if
one of your mowers goes down your truck
breaks like all all the business numbers
i'm talking right now are separate
accounts
the tempting thing when you're starting
a side business is you just run it
through your personal accounts and you
don't want to do that so i want you to
have a separate business separate
checking and out of that you'll you'll
know okay um
my expenses roughly to operate this or
you know whatever three to six months of
that just like we teach you in personal
set that aside in a savings account
that's super accessible
and then you want to save for large
expenses so if you're saving up for hey
i know this mower is about to go out i'm
going to need a new one by next year or
i need the what are they called zero
turn all these fancy things that you
know in the world
if you're saving up for some of that
stuff then you would save that in a
separate savings account again just like
in the personal we save up for large
purchases
after you've saved for taxes after
you've covered all your expenses
um
after you've got your emergency fund and
that type of thing then what's left is
yours that's the profit that's the
beauty of running a business and so it
it sounds like you guys are doing really
well the one thing i want you to keep in
mind and i'm sure you've thought of this
david this i'm not telling anything you
don't know but i do want to remind you
you're going into winter and so since
your business is so seasonal i want you
to look at how you've done this year and
then also look at how you're going to be
able to maintain
some level of income income or
sustainability in these off seasons and
ramp it back up in the spring and that
type of thing but it can be pretty basic
and as you as you move to full time um
and maybe even before but but when
you're ready to move to full time i
definitely recommend getting a cpa to
help you often they will save you more
than they cost you and it's just great
to have a professional in your corner
doing all the technical tax stuff
because i'm not an expert in that i'm
guessing you're not either david and so
we need someone that is to help us
okay yeah i really appreciate the
information yeah well great job great
job starting your business way to go
he's crushing it i mean march of this
year yeah and already already like oh
yeah
this is a really interesting time to
start a business george because so many
people are i mean ken coleman has been
talking about the great resignation 95
of people are considering doing
something different
something i think david said this where
something about
covet and your world being turned upside
down makes you look at your life
differently and go i don't know am i
happy in my job i don't know do i want
to spend more time with my kids do i
want to do something different and i
think you're seeing businesses maybe
starting on the side which is a great
way to start springing up out of this
kind of mid-life crisis slash revelation
of like hey maybe i could do my own
thing and they're doing it making more
money by the way yeah in their business
uh
there's not really a season as a ceiling
there's not a cap on that in many
businesses and i think that's really
cool of the the innovation the
creativity the scrappiness that's coming
out of the last couple years of crazy
that a lot of a lot of small businesses
are starting so it's a great time people
are going hey you know what there's a
lot of things i can't control that
scared me this year and what if i could
be my boss and what if i could do that
thing i've always wanted to do now that
my life is a little more flexible that's
right and i'm working remotely or
whatever those things are and so people
are starting to have this kind of
existential crisis you know it doesn't
take a midlife crisis anymore it just
takes a pandemic well you know you know
what's so interesting too and i'll say
this really quickly but
you over the last decade specifically
i've been i've been coaching business
leaders through business boutique the
last six seven years but even over the
last decade you've seen this massive
rise inside businesses solopreneurs
freelancers independent workers contract
workers whatever you want to call it
home-based businesses
and what's so interesting is you have
all these people getting into business
that know their craft in david's case
landscaping and lawn care in someone
else's case making jewelry someone else
a fitness coach they know they're
thinking they love their thing and they
want to make money doing their thing and
they can
what trips them up though is the
business stuff and they think oh but
what about taxes well what about the
money management i don't know how to do
social media i don't know email
marketing they get caught up in the
business side of stuff and the thing
that i just want to remind people of and
encourage them is
that feels really big and overwhelming
because it's unknown
most business owners will tell you 95 of
the job is doing that thing you love the
jewelry the fitness coaching the
landscaping yeah there's five to ten
percent of operations there's five to
ten percent of you need someone help you
taxes you need some business stuff uh
but it's once you have someone explain
it to you and once you have someone walk
with you and just get some help in those
areas it really does make it so much
more uh so much less intimidating we're
like oh i can do this maybe i can do
this business stuff so it's just a it's
a great time to do business it's why i
love helping people through business
boutique when you get the help you need
you'll realize the majority of the
business is doing that thing you love to
do yeah and you've got the academy that
just opened up the business academy
which rolls perfectly with all the small
business what is that for who is that
for so that that is my coaching group
this is my online training and coaching
group we open twice a year where i walk
with you for the next six months and
basically i'm your coach you get access
to live sessions with me where i do
things like answering david's question
where i'll answer questions for what
you're dealing with what you need help
with i teach you how to raise your
prices i teach you how to post content
on social media teach you how to have an
email campaign i teach you some business
best practices that you can apply to
your specific business so it doesn't
matter what type of business you're in
you're all in business and that's
actually my sweet spot that's what i
know that's my background i'm a
certified business coach so i take what
i know and love
and help these business owners these
side business leaders small business
whatever side gig i help them do what
they love i take the intimidation factor
out of the business stuff and so yeah so
we're open until thursday night you go
to business boutique.com get your spot
it's 244 dollars for the next six months
which is a steal it's like 40 bucks a
month for coaching which is crazy i
think you're going to save for like one
session yeah
that's what you've been charging me
christy and getting ready
that's incredible this is huge because a
lot of people get stuck especially when
they go i love doing this thing but now
that it's a business and there's profits
i got to make money doing this it gets
stressful and you can help really give
them the confidence that they're making
the right decisions well what's
interesting is i've done research on
this for years business owners they get
excited they get creative they put their
thing on facebook they made a quilt they
cut someone's lawn like hey maybe i
could do this
they get all excited at first which is
awesome
but then eventually pretty early on they
hit a wall and where they get
overwhelmed and the determining factor
on whether or not they make it over the
wall is if they get help i have years of
research to show this i'm like hey let
me help them get over the wall and then
by the way you can actually do this you
can actually stick with it so good well
i'm really excited about if you guys
want to check that out go to
businessboutique.com business boutique
academy open through thursday and then
it shuts down for another six months
that's right we're going into the
hibernation the new members check it out
while you can christy wright she's the
best in the business more the ramsay
show coming up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by christy wright
it's a free call triple eight eight two
five five two two five in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
with the matching t-shirts it is derek
and amber how you guys doing
we're doing really good we're nervous
but we're good oh you're gonna hurry
it's just me no one has ever claimed
that i'm in intimidating no one is
scared of george we can't start with
y'all
so where are you guys from
we're from salt lake city utah very nice
okay so let's talk about this how much
debt have you guys paid off we paid off
61
373 dollars awesome and how long did
that take that took us eight months
eight months yeah and what was your
range of income during this time we
started about uh 44 000 and ended in
about 160.
oh i'm gonna need that story yeah
did someone get a job here how did you
quadruple your income
um well
kovid kind of came and i was working at
a youth treatment center and they didn't
need the help anymore
and he's a tattoo artist and his shop
closed
and we were actually living off
unemployment and my student loans
and that's why our income was so low
and then things started opening up and i
finished school and i got a job at the
social worker in child welfare and then
he went back to work so and plus we had
some side hustles in there so wow so the
business came back with a fury
apparently yes we were ready were people
coming out of the pandemic going i need
tattoos man what's going on here
seriously
i just um
all i did was work you know and and and
my books just started feeling and i and
i um
so so during
um
when coveted cam i mean when we closed
down i actually uh were both recovering
addicts i ended up relapsing and i went
to jail and um
so we during that time i mean i didn't
we didn't have my income you know
um
i ended up getting out of jail and um i
went to a treatment center and then uh
we read the book again
and uh we started listening to this
podcast this podcast every day it was
our motivation and um back in november
we we downloaded that app uh the every
dollar app and just stuck to it and um
listened to the podcast every day that
was our motivation i went back to work
she graduated college and went and went
to work and um
we worked every day every day
tell me about that's so interesting as a
part of your story tell me about how
having this goal
and this plan
affected your relationship affected your
stability affected your focus in other
areas of your life having this this plan
that that you guys were so disciplined
about how did that affect other areas of
your life
um i think
for us it affected our communication so
i mean we we had to really sit down i
mean i thought i was gonna have my
student loans forever like i just
accepted that like i'm just gonna have
this payment forever but like sitting
down and and like it takes courage to
look at yourself and be like okay well i
spent way too much money eating out or
do you know what i mean like to be able
to talk to each other he didn't know how
much student loan debt i had fully was
this all of your debt the 61 000 in
student loans no
what was it what kind of debt was this
we had uh student loans um
that was my major portion but we also
had car loans we had medical bills we
had um
i when i when i went to jail i ended up
racking up back some back child support
um we
we had a little bit of credit card um we
even had dead on our phones i mean we
think we upgraded our phone through our
service and we you know just everywhere
um
yeah so what got you started on this
journey eight months ago to go you know
what this is it no more
so i mean it was a couple years
a couple years ago a friend of mine had
given uh i didn't know what audibles was
back then and he had given me the book
the total money makeover and i we
listened to it and then we were kind of
dave ramsey is she know for a little bit
but then when the pandemic came um when
we both lost their jobs um
and and that whole situation happened
with with me going to jail and um
when when i
it's just what happened what i mean was
i nervous
we um
we're just listening to the podcast
every day um and starting every dollar
out that's that's what changed us um it
was the motivation hearing everybody's
stories um
it was it was nice and it was losing
like being so low and being scared yeah
um with neither one of us working even
though we had the unemployment it was we
were still like kind of living paycheck
to paycheck are we going to be able to
pay the rent are we going to be able to
buy food we had our car payments
um and so i think being kind of and then
him going and i was by myself
you know i was scared i didn't have an
emergency fund to pay the rent yeah um
we didn't have anything to fall back on
but having that now it's kind of
it's nice
talk to me about now like you guys have
been through it in the last two years
what does it feel like now standing on
that stage you're completely debt free
you have an incredible income you've
turned your life around what does that
feel like
um it's free
um and peaceful actually um
like my whole life i think like i've
always waited for payday you know when
payday like let's
i can't do this because i don't get paid
like i i forget about painting payday
now
i mean i get reminded by people at work
they're like it's payday and i'm like oh
[Laughter]
we were able to bring his parents on
this trip they've never been out here um
we we came early and we went and ran the
spartan race we can
travel and do the spartan races like we
like to do and
um
i think it's just strengthened us and
and motivated us even in more ways to
just continue with our kids
my son he saved a lot of money and
bought his own car six thousand dollars
wow awesome
we actually have envelopes for his kids
um
and his daughter is the sweetest we she
put money we don't tell them where to
put their money and we'll have like a
payday meeting on sunday they do jobs
around the house they have to check it
off and
she was putting money in her give
envelope because we're on baby step 3b
so we want to buy a house
and she was putting the money in her
envelope and we looked at her and we're
like what do you plan to give like
what's your plan and she says well i'm
gonna i'm gonna keep putting money in
there and i'm gonna give it to you guys
to help buy the house
oh my gosh
incredible yeah look at the look at the
example you're setting but the legacy
you're creating you guys are amazing you
all are amazing well thank you for being
here and sharing your story well story
of resilience i know it's going to
inspire someone out there who maybe be
going through something that you guys
were eight months ago a year ago so
thank you for being here we've got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
that's obviously the next step for you
guys and you're changing your family
tree in so many ways not just with money
but you guys have taken control in all
kinds of areas and we have a copy of the
total money makeover i know that
inspired you and it's going to inspire
someone else so you can pay that forward
so we're so honored you guys made the
trip to be here tell me what the
t-shirts say on there yeah so i'm gonna
read hers he's the tattoo artist so he
designed him i love it so we have
matching ones on the front that say team
beast
her says
if broke people are making fun of your
financial plan you're on the right track
i'm debt-free
i love it and now you guys get to scream
it okay you ready you got a little bit
more
so it says don't buy things you can't
afford with money you don't have to
impress people you don't like
brilliant that's perfect that's a long
tattoo to put on skin but it works great
on a t-shirt okay let's do this guys
it's derek and amber from salt lake city
61 thousand dollars paid off in eight
months making 44 to 160 thousand dollars
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one we're
[Applause]
oh this is one of my favorites i've seen
in a long time look at them
i love that so much
i wish everybody listening could have
seen that man oh yeah go watch that on
go watch that on youtube you know so
cool as they said one of the keys to
staying motivated on their journey was
hearing other people's story that kept
them motivated and now
they get to be that story that is
motivating someone listening right now
that's going to stay with it that's a
dead free screen beautiful it never gets
old somehow christine 30 years a day of
doing this i could hear him all day long
puts a smile on your face gives us some
hope that people are out there willing
to transform and change their lives but
they have to decide and derek and amber
decided we're gonna do things
differently we're so proud of you guys
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm george
campbell joined today by ramsey
personality and number one best-selling
author christy wright we are taking your
calls on life money relationships
balance family you name it triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number now right now you're probably
focused on all the false stuff you've
gotta buy halloween candy the jackets
the sweaters but here's what you should
start thinking about right now i know
it's early christmas
it seems to sneak up on people every
year and when you let that happen it's
easy to go crazy on overspending or
worse put christmas on a credit card
don't do it
but when you plan ahead with a budget
you'll keep christmas from getting out
of control the best way to do that is
with our budgeting tool every dollar
start your christmas budget now by
deciding how much you want to save each
month and you can plug that into your
every dollar budget so you can pay for
christmas in cash it's possible then
when you start shopping your every
dollar makes it easy to keep up with how
much you're spending on gifts and by the
way it's totally free to get started
you can also upgrade to a ramsey plus
membership and get premium features with
every dollar like banksync that allows
you to just drag and drop your
transactions into your budget and all
kinds of custom reports to show you
where your money's going guys christmas
is coming it's not a surprise and this
year you can enjoy the holiday how it
should be stress free and debt free
start budgeting with every dollar by
texting the word budget to 33789 that's
budget to
33789 all right let's go to the phones
william is in columbia missouri william
welcome to the ramsey show
hi george hi chrissy uh real quick
question
i'm going into a divorce um before we
were separated about two years ago we're
completely debt-free
um i have about ten thousand dollars in
an emergency fund and facing the divorce
i'm kind of afraid of
that money getting split and
you know i i basically lose out on it
and there's a lot of things i've been
holding off on
upgrading you know my my phone is eight
years old my computer's 10 years old my
car is 13 years old
and i've got things that i can put it on
and you know children's college funds
and stuff and so i i'm very hesitant to
spend that money because you know i
really like having a stockpile of cash
that i can deal with emergencies but
then i'm also really not a big fan of
the idea of
you know just half of it going away and
i have no control on it
well william i'm so sorry you're going
through that how fresh is this divorce
well filed two years ago and it's still
pinning in the court and the co-vid kind
of messed with things quite a bit
so you've been going through this for a
while now
is the is all the money stuff separate
what's going on financially
um
when we separated
i got a separate bank account i've been
doing all my banking stuff separately
i am still like i said you know i'm
still debt-free
she has
been using a different approach on her
finances
and
um
i
i don't know how much legally
those things are going to be considered
separate even though they have been
separate
um
but yeah so
like i said i'm just worried about
just giving away money that isn't being
used for
the way i think it should be used
and but then again i don't want to give
up
you know having an emergency fund
here's what's interesting though william
i just want to help you think through
this from
a couple different angles because you're
going through a really tough time right
now and so obviously that's affecting
how you're looking at the money it's not
just money it's there's there's an
emotional context around it right now
let's pretend there's a scenario where
you're not going through a divorce
would you you gave some very valid
purchases that may need to happen from a
car to a phone to whatever
um
if you were not
going through a divorce and that was not
part of the factor with this decision
would you need that money to fix those
solutions is it an emergency is it
something where you're like i need to
replace my phone because it's dying
tomorrow or my car or you know whatever
is it an emergency that you actually
need to use this money for
outside of the divorce situation
right
yes ish
it's you know that's
i've been really holding off on doing
any of those upgrades or maintenance
kind of stuff that does need to happen
just because i don't know what you know
next week or next month looks like
um and so there's a lot of stuff that
does need to happen
um
if the personal life were more
stabilized then i would be able to
predict and schedule those things a lot
more effectively
and so there are some things that need
to happen
um i don't know that it's necessarily
critical as in like the next week or
next month but it is stuff that
definitely needs to happen within the
next year or so yeah okay so let's look
at this differently okay let's look at
there's a difference between an
emergency
and an upgrade that you plan on it
sounds like these are upgrades that you
can plan on not emergencies that need to
come out of your emergency fund you can
save and upgrade your phone you can save
and upgrade your car and those are
things that you can start working on
without dipping into your emergency fund
but the thing that i want you to keep in
mind is
if you spend this money this ten
thousand dollars in your emergency fund
on something just to use it up or if
half of it goes to your soon-to-be
ex-wife either way the money's gone you
don't have the money anymore
what we tell people to not make
decisions based on fear or it's like
what-if scenarios what if what if you
have no idea how this is gonna go and
then you're just spending it up to try
to avoid something that maybe half of
it's gone but either way
it's it's gone because you don't have
the money anymore because you've spent
it on that thing so what i would
encourage you to do and this is this is
more of a
a gray area it's a tough time it's not
like oh we have a
baby step for a specific you know in
this scenario but what we do encourage
you to do is not make decisions based on
fear not jump the gun because of what if
this side or the other right now you
have an emergency fund you can hold on
to that you can save for these upgrades
of a car phone whatever and then if
something happens and you then five
thousand of it you still have five
thousand left that you didn't
waste on something and then if not then
you have all of it you still have your
emergency fund intact i just
you know when when people call in george
sometimes they call and say well should
i stop paying on my debt in case i lose
my job and we're like well are is there
a sign you're going to lose your job no
well do you know your no and so
sometimes we can get into that
worry state where we make decisions with
our money today based on something that
could happen it may happen or may not
and so we just want to go based on the
information we have today today you
don't have any emergencies that need
that money spent on it so i wouldn't
spend them on them it's not an emergency
you can save and upgrade those things if
you need to yeah if i were you william
do you have any any margin right now
since you're debt-free do you have cash
flow coming in that's not going towards
bills and things
um it's pretty tight my money comes
around 40 000 a year and i've been
paying her you know each month just even
though it's not legally required for
child support i have been um but that
makes the margin pretty tight i'm in the
black maybe 100 bucks a month
well
i would want things kind of legally
stated as part of the settlement before
you start doing things outside of that
so
if this thing's over i want it to be
over two years is a long time to drag
this thing out so if there's anything in
your power you can do to move it along
to get some finality so that you can
move on with your life and move on with
your finances i would do that but to
christie's point these are things that
you need to be cash flowing they're not
true emergencies we have three questions
we ask when it comes to emergencies is
it urgent is it necessary and is it
unexpected and a lot of these things you
told me they're really not unexpected
they're just kind of wearing out and so
make it a line item in your budget maybe
even if it's 50 bucks a month towards
the phone and 100 bucks towards the
laptop whatever you can muster up maybe
it's you take a side job right now if
you've got the bandwidth to do that to
bring in extra income to get these
things taken care of
but unless you actually had something go
wrong with the car that is when you
could dip into that and i want you to
feel free to do that you've worked hard
to have the security blanket so use it
when you need it but don't let it become
a fun money well i just want to upgrade
my life real quick so i deplete myself
with this money so do it the smart way
but make sure that you are doing a
monthly budget and if you hang on the
line i'll have kelly pick up and i'll
gift you one year of ramsay plus and i
just mentioned that every dollar budget
that's going to really help you dial in
every single expense as you go through
this divorce so
hang on the line kelly will pick up
and once you get into ramsay plus i want
you to do two things number one create
your every dollar budget and it'll
connect to your bank account so you can
literally drag and drop things coming in
give every dollar a name and make sure
that you have a plan along with that you
can go through financial peace
university and get some fresh reminders
if you haven't gone through it this is
going to educate you and give you the
motivation you need especially coming
out of this divorce christy this is a
really really hard season and you need
to have people alongside you tools
alongside of you to help push you
through this yeah and then once you know
exactly what the what the the
circumstances are what all the
conditions are around the divorce you'll
be able to set that budget much more
expected because right now i hear it in
your voice you've got some fear of the
unknown and so once that's behind you
you can have a fresh start a budget you
can plan on that's really going to help
you i think have peace of mind and
confidence in that yeah right now
there's not a lot of clarity for him and
that's why i want this thing finalized
so he knows the terms and knows how to
move forward with his budget well that
puts this hour of the show in the books
my thanks to james childs our producer
kelly daniel associate producer and
phone screener and of course my fabulous
co-host christy wright we'll be back
with you before you know it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
do
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and money
and family and relationships and all
sorts of fun stuff i am joined today by
christy wright ramsay personality i'm
george campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast and might
i mentioned christy uh big
congratulations for a number one
national best-selling book last week
yeah it was huge and i don't know if you
heard this but in week two it hit the
best seller list again so this is two
weeks in a row of bestseller list wow
i'm so excited and the the coolest part
of putting any project out in the world
but it's seeing the stories the feedback
that it really is helping people so
thank you super excited super grateful
for the team that pulled it off and uh
yeah the number one thing people are
saying is it's not just another time
management book and gosh that was the
exact heart behind it so yeah super fun
take back your time the guilt-free guide
to balance it's a great book get it for
everyone in your life to tell them that
you love them sure right that's what you
do
all right open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five
two give us a call about just about
anything at this point we'll try we'll
do our best money
money always
life time management relationships but
you all know i love helping people in
business we've got the business boutique
conference next week this week my online
coaching group is open so i'm kind of on
this business kick so maybe you've got a
question about how to grow your business
how to pay yourself or maybe
you are one of those people that you're
in baby step two and you want to pay off
your debt faster you're like i'm going
to start a side gig
what should i do i can help you come up
with a business idea or tell you if your
idea is good or not see i'm going to
tell you the truth if it's good or not
so if you've got a business question
give us a call i'd love to help you out
as well we heard some inspiring stories
in our staff meeting this morning from
team members yes who got a little
gazelle intense and started some side
gigs to pay off their debt and there was
all kinds of things beef jerky
businesses yes selling that on the side
yes they were shipping coins weirdest
weirdest ones shipping coins and getting
them sorted and then sent a check yeah
we're like okay i i think this is legal
but i'm not sure so many questions what
was happening someone at the irs is
listening give us a call and we'll we'll
get through it i was laughing so hard
but also so proud of their scrappiness
yeah like that's that's one of the
things i love about small business
people and even side business people
whatever you're just scrappy man people
think you need a a degree to be super
sophisticated to win in business no you
just gotta be scrappy i love seeing that
that's really cool all right open phones
sam is on the line in new york city sam
welcome to the ramsay show
hey guys what's going on hey how are you
how can we help
you god i'm doing good basically my
dilemma is this i'm a senior in college
and
i'm majoring in business management
they instituted a vaccine mandate and
they they denied my religious exemption
request
so where i'm at is
you know i don't graduate i was ready to
graduate in may so when that is now i
transfer to a
get a random online degree
you know i feel like that's gonna affect
me
down the down the road what do you guys
think
okay so it's in business management is
what your degree's in
right okay where uh well tell me this
what is your concern about the online
just the fact that it's online that it
doesn't have some type of reputation
like the the school you went to or is it
this specific online school that you're
not just believing in as much
well yeah it just i mean i put in i
already invested so many years and so
much money to get this degree from you
know
and now to just go online
i just feel like it's not it's not the
same or am i overreacting
well i i just want to say i'm sorry that
happened um
i'm sorry you have put in the time and
now you're finishing out in a way that
you didn't want to
and i'm sorry because that's that
there's a little bit of of loss there to
grief you know like i thought it was
going to go this way and it didn't and
um and i hear that here's what i'll say
sam on my side of things of working for
this organization we hire a ton of
people i'm a certified business coach i
have hired plenty of people in my life
what people are looking for
has so much more
to do with
who you are
how you interview the skills that you
have the experience that you have then
the title on your degree i know you're
disappointed and i just want to say
that's valid i i can't you know i can't
blame you there just because you didn't
think it was going to go this way
i don't think it's going to keep you
from getting the job that you want i
think what's going to get you the job
that you want is you
i think experience networking doing what
ken coleman teaches getting around the
people that are doing what you want to
do getting an internship this year
getting your foot in the door building
relationships getting some experience
solving problems showing your skills
developing your skills helping people
that's what's going to get at your job
that's what's going to get you promotion
it's not a degree you're disappointed
and i get that but i just want to
encourage you i don't think that that's
going to hold you back
um i don't think that's what was going
to get you the job before and i don't
think it's going to keep you from
getting the job now i don't know george
what do you think i i think comes out of
the person yeah i've got questions about
your do your credits transfer i mean how
much are you losing here when it comes
to education
so i was going to graduate in may if i
transfer i have another year and a half
left it looks like
oh on top of that i didn't realize that
i thought it was the same track record
you are losing a good chunk of time by
switching to the online why
why
they don't they don't actually offer any
online it would be a different school
right but i'm saying can you find us i
was a transfer student i transferred
from the university of central florida
to university of tennessee knoxville
after a year and a half and all but like
four credits transferred i found the
school i wanted to go to those in-state
school to get in-state tuition can you
find an online school that will accept
the majority of your credits where
you're only having to finish out and
maybe there's a couple that don't
transfer
that's my question got it
yeah so a part of it is because i spent
a year abroad
so the squamon counted that for credit
but a lot of these online um schools
aren't counting that towards credit my
year abroad that i spent and the school
isn't uh willing to let you finish out
online is there a way to do that
no
yeah no they won't
interesting what school is this
size sim school of business okay
well i would do i would do some more
research and dig into it i don't want
you to just make this jump without
having all of the information possible
so now that you're going online i mean
the world is your oyster yeah you can
you can do any program and a lot of
these online programs are actually
really good now you don't have to go
with like a sketchy online university
you can find a lot of accredited
universities online with online programs
so i would call up every single one that
is an option that you can cash flow and
figure out who's going to take the most
credits so that you spend the least
amount of money and the least amount of
time to finish out this degree yeah i
didn't understand that sam about adding
so much time to your education i totally
agree i don't i don't want you to do
that either i'm
taking online classes right now through
fuller
seminary classes and i chose that to
your point george because i could choose
any school i wanted to because it's
online i was able to choose the one that
had the classes i wanted the program i
wanted so sam i think it might just take
some more research and digging to find a
school that's a better fit for your
specific program that might accept those
study abroad credits um that you can
customize and have less time yeah less
time don't add on all these
semesters if you don't have to in the
cost yeah yeah i agree i think there's
more out there i think you might have to
do some digging to find it and i think
it'll be worth it if you do sam can you
cash flow this experience regardless
yeah
okay well that's good that's a that's a
big up right there so i think you need
to do some research and like christy
said sam is the determining factor here
not the degree the question is are you
good at business management and uh get
your feet in the door somewhere i mean i
start earn and my degree really was was
not a huge part of that discussion i
started here as a project manager so you
and i both have stories of starting out
doing what we could where we were yeah
yep start with where you are with what
you got sam you got this man this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
i'm george campbell host of the fine
print and entree leadership podcast i'm
joined by christy wright today national
bestselling author and host of the
christie ride show and it's open phones
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five ryan joyce joins us in
cleveland ohio ryan welcome to the
ramsay show
hey good afternoon hey
what's going on how can we help
i'm just looking for some wisdom and
hopefully some guidance uh like you said
my name's ryan i'm a single 22 year old
from the greater cleveland area
currently i don't have an emergency fund
because i've been living paycheck to
paycheck and my current debt is around 3
720
to my question i'm having a little bit
of a tough month uh i have a vehicle
worth about fifteen hundred dollars that
needs repair repairs equal to or kind of
more than its value
um by month's end i'll be in possession
of about three thousand hundred 300
um i want to spend that money with
intention and make the right decision
should i spend 1500 on repairs and use
the remaining 1800 to take a large chunk
out of that debt or should i sell the
vehicle approximately for a thousand
dollars and spend three to four thousand
dollars on a new vehicle leaving my debt
mostly for a future month
um what do you do ryan
i am currently in uh sales okay out of
curiosity how are you just you said that
kind of like this is a gift or
unexpected three thousand dollars you're
gonna have at the end of the month is
this just a big bonus check from a good
month for you or is this what is this
money coming in from
so when i got my tax return i made some
impulse purchases i've always been a
spender and uh i have gone ahead and
returned those so i am anticipating a a
an amount almost equal to my tax return
and refund gotcha okay
and this 3 dollars in debt what was that
from what kind of debt is that um i have
i have the numbers actually down here i
have one thousand nine hundred and
eighty three dollars uh from a personal
loan i have one thousand one hundred and
thirty seven dollars from a credit card
and then i have an additional 600 that i
owe my parents
okay
so it sounds like a lot of this is
stemming from a spending problem is that
correct
i would say so okay and this 3 300 is
coming in i do want you to be wise with
it i'm glad that that you gave us a call
uh if i'm you i'm doing that repair
because it's gonna be really hard right
now to find a car for fifteen hundred
dollars or two thousand dollars so if
i'm you and this and this is like a
repair that is needed i mean is this
thing really
on the rocks this car
correct and have you shopped around to
make sure that you can't get it cheaper
elsewhere
yeah i'm a car salesman oh well that
helps
uh is there like a loaner car that they
could let you drive around
no we don't do that as a dealership
sadly okay i figured that was at least
one perk of the job apparently not uh so
yeah doesn't hurt to ask i think you
need to just go ahead and do this repair
because you're going to have a hard time
finding anything but you need to really
get focused on this debt as soon as this
car is repaired so any extra money
coming in the spending is is no more
because you've got yourself in a pickle
here you're in debt you don't have any
money in savings and you've got this car
repair and um is it stressful to have
this repair looming in your life with no
money
absolutely
so what i want for you is some financial
foundation and what that means is once
you get this repair done and you start
tackling this debt you've got to have a
thousand dollars saved in an emergency
fund because you said right now you have
zero savings so if i'm you with that 33
coming in i'm gonna put a thousand
dollars into savings for baby step one
that's your thousand dollar starter
emergency fund then you're gonna put
1500 towards this repair and get this
thing fixed up and that's still going to
leave you with a good chunk of money to
then start attacking this debt do i have
those numbers right
yeah are you doing a monthly budget
right now
not currently okay that's a1 so what i
want you to do is uh jump onto every
dollar you can download the app go
online and i'll actually gift you ramsey
plus and within that you're going to get
every dollar plus that's our premium
budgeting tool and this is going to help
you give every dollar a name and
especially for a spender like you this
is what you need you got to get this
thing rained in and go all right i've
got goals in life and one of those goals
is to not be stressed over a car repair
especially when you're in sales and
you've got uh you know irregular income
coming in i'm guessing right it's
largely commissioned correct okay and
since you're in sales it also means you
have a little bit of control you can get
your butt selling some cars right now
and guess what people are buying them
aren't they
yes uh okay what's your income ryan
uh so currently i make about thirty six
thousand dollars on a draw um and uh so
that's excluding potential commission um
and then next year i go up to forty
eight thousand dollars okay
that's awesome well the good news is you
don't have a ton of debt you should be
able to knock this out pretty quick even
if you go i mean you're going to have
this thousand dollar emergency fund that
we're that george is talking about the
car etc whatever but even if you just
you got these returns like the tax
return you did those returns look around
your house you got some old iphones old
headphones old ipad any technology you
can sell look around your house if you
start getting scrappy and selling some
stuff i bet you can find a few more
extra 100 bucks and you can knock out
this debt pretty quickly absolutely it's
a small amount kelly's gonna pick up and
she will gift you that one year
membership to ramsay plus get on every
dollar get on a plan and you'll be all
right my man sasha joins us in san jose
sasha welcome to the ramsay show
hi thanks how are you good is it sasha i
feel like i said it wrong
yeah i know you said it right
the first time okay great how are you
doing
i'm doing good what can we help with
um i just have a question it's kind of
about me and my husband um
he's in school right now but he's also
working 30 to 40 hours a week
and i graduated um but he's kind of
not doing so well with his schoolwork
but he's hesitant to like lean back on
working so much because we are paying
off our debt as well um which a lot of
it is my student loans um and with my
income i could afford to support us both
but then i wouldn't be able to make any
extra payments to our debt so i just
kind of wanted some guidance of what
we should do
so to recap his his school work is
suffering but you guys are trying to pay
off this debt and so it's going to slow
down the debt payoff process if he cuts
back on his work hours
yes
how much debt do you have
um it's about
55 000
if if you keep track on the track that
you're on how long will it take you to
pay it off
it would be about a year and a half
okay for two years are his are his
grades bad enough that it's affecting
his gpa and affecting his ability to
graduate
yes so right now it's like kind of at
the point where he's he could do better
but with the time restraints he's not
able to really
focus on improving and so i've noticed
that
what what he's doing right now isn't
working so i'm just worried it's going
to keep going down
what's he going to school for what's the
why behind this um school decision out
of curiosity
um accounting and finance
cool so we're pass flowing his school up
to but that's mostly my student debt
well i mean
i'll jump in from just a time standpoint
because that's what jumps out to me you
know as i hear this question um more
than the money it's the time i mean you
only have so much time and not only do
you only have so much time you only have
so much energy and your husband only has
so much energy even if you bust it
there's a point of diminishing returns
there's a point where when we try to do
more than we can fit in our finite time
um something starts to suffer and so to
me what jumps out to me and george you
jump in especially from the money side
of this but i'll just say this um it
might just be prioritizing these goals
if getting debt free is the number one
goal it might be schools on hold until
we get debt free you can make an
argument for that if you want to do it
the other way that's fine he does school
and you support you guys and you don't
make those extra payments until he's
graduated fine i think you're trying to
do everything all the time and these are
big goals getting debt free is a big
goal school is a big goal um and even
the accounting degree even if it
you know if you are paying for this
degree and then he's not going to be
able to pass the classes then you're
losing money and time and he's exhausted
you'll start to see a an effect in your
marriage you'll start to see effect in
other areas of your life in the work and
so on and so i would just encourage you
to make some decisions it's not that you
can't do these both of these things
might just not be a good idea to do them
both at the same time and this is from
just a your time is finite your energy
is finite similar to money we got to
prioritize and put them in order yeah
and if there's any other job he can do
where maybe he's making as much but
doing half half the time maybe he's
doing 20 hours a week but it's making
more money and if you're able to pick up
some slack and start to work a little
bit as well that'll keep i can tell that
they want to pay off this debt so i
don't want you to lose that momentum but
like christy said right now he's in
school and he's trying to do this thing
and you're trying to do a lot at once
and i don't want that to cause you to
lose steam and not graduate which was
the whole point so uh this is a decision
you guys have to make together
regardless get on the same page i don't
want him burning out this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by my
friend christy wright it's open phones
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five we've got greg and
sarah on the line in kansas city
missouri greg and sarah i hear a little
rumor that you guys are debt-free
yeah that's right george we are
debt-free we paid off 86 000
in 28 months
wow way to go congratulations guys what
was your range of income during that
time
i'm sorry what was your range of income
range of income we started at 104 104
000
up to 114 000 with side hustles and then
back down to 112 000 at the end nice
fantastic now what kind of debt was this
um just credit cards car payments a debt
settlement company agreement just a
whole bunch of mess
and you guys decided 28 months ago that
you're done with dealing with this mess
what happened
yeah so the story is basically we had uh
when we got married i was the one the
nerd that managed our finances fast
forward through 14 years worth of
spending more than we made and we had
eight credit cards that were maxed out
two car payments and just couldn't
afford it all and i'd been doing it
myself god got a hold of me and
convicted me and said you need to get
on the same page with this with your
wife
and so we
started working through this and our
pastor at our church suggested we sit
down with
the couple that led the financial peace
course at our church and we started
getting coaching with them
wow so when you said god convicted me
what did that look like because i
imagine a lot of wives are hoping their
husbands are convicted as well
they're saying a prayer right now
yes exactly
yeah i mean it was some some rough times
um
where i just had to come clean and say
god
i haven't been
managing our money the way that it
needed to be managed and i need your
help i need
we need to do this together as a team
and i can't do it myself anymore wow
that's powerful
so what do you guys do for a living
i am a software engineer and i'm a
stay-at-home mom
wow so this was all your income
great yes yeah i mean it's
my income mostly but i mean she's
contributed a lot with with side hustles
with selling stuff yeah i sold all kinds
of stuff that was what i did sold stuff
and i did some mystery shopping on the
side just anything to bring in extra
income what was the most lucrative side
hustle you did
um i mean i think i took a part-time job
in addition to my full-time job where i
did the good old dave ramsey standby of
delivering pizzas nice do you remember
what you made delivering pizzas
um that was about ten thousand a year
wow
everything it was about two to three
nights a week delivering pizzas
that's awesome so what would you say the
key was for you guys to uh to get out of
debt
um i'd say probably the first thing was
i couldn't have done it without my wife
without god providing for us but i mean
i was made the mess by myself and the
key was doing it together
yeah and i would say being consistent
and even if we made some mistakes we got
right back up and started off we we just
picked up where we left off that's
awesome we didn't give up
i'm curious i want to go back really
quickly to a partner story where you
guys were talking about greg you're
talking about being convicted of not
handling money well when you described
your debt it was all really normal
credit cards i mean this is how normal
people live
for you what was the moment that you
realized that there must be a different
way to live there must be a different
way to manage your money did it even
created the hope and consideration that
something else was possible because i
think so many people just accept that
that is how you live that is how you
manage money that's normal what was it
for you that helps you consider maybe
there's something different
um i mean i think it just got to the
point where it was more relational
than anything i mean she
wanted to be involved and at that point
there was such a mess
anyways and i was just um consumed by
fear and shame
that we had been working so hard for so
many years and didn't have anything to
show for it yeah and god just really
convicted me that said that i needed to
just come clean and humbly come before
her and ask for her for forgiveness for
not
doing a good job in that area yeah you
guys are amazing sometimes it takes that
it's like i don't know
what to do next but i know what i'm
doing it's not working so that was that
was me when i
i
we were going through the debt
settlement companies and i said i think
that we can do something else i don't i
think we can do this on our own i don't
think we need this debt settlement
company so that's when we went and
talked to our pastor and he directed us
to fpu awesome yeah that's really cool
just seeing a plan just seeing a plan of
how it's possible yeah that's one of the
most powerful tools i've heard is just
going through it sounds so simple it's
like you just want to watch videos
together and this is all going to happen
what was that spark that made you guys
go all right we're on the same page now
we've got the same language when it
comes to this this plan
i mean i think once we started knocking
um deaths off the list we're like okay
we can do this it feels so good
enough okay i i think we can do this
there you go um
and once we just started knocking things
off the list we were just like
this is why this has worked for six
million other people
you realize we're not special we can do
this too so who are you who are the
cheerleaders along the way
um i'd say cheerleaders um are church
leaders i had an accountability partner
um
parents were understanding along the way
just with realizing that we were having
to work more and just being very
supportive of that and just each other
yeah each other i would agree each other
that's awesome so how does it feel to be
debt-free
it's amazing i mean it's amazing to know
that
we can do things with our money now that
we couldn't do
throughout most of our marriage and just
not to have to worry i mean we have a
plan we still follow a budget
but to be able to do things with our
finances that we couldn't do before
someone wants us to or needs
um us to help contribute some money at a
church
or um to help some neighbors out we look
at each other it's like okay let's do it
yeah that's awesome generosity it
becomes a lot easier to just go yep
we're doing that we got the margin you
work so hard and you actually get to
keep your money it's just the simplest
things that make you feel so free and
you guys all your hard work paid off
well done y'all
how old are you
um i am 41
and 37. wow have you ever been debt free
in your adult life
no no wow incredible changing your
family tree that's right that's what
it's all about the inspiration is to do
this for our kids yep that's the idea
or real proud of you guys honored to uh
share your story with the world we've
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter in your story as
you build wealth and give and we also
have a copy of the total money makeover
so you can pass this along to another
family who needs this inspiration who
needs to know hey i can do this if we
get on the same page we can get rid of
this debt so let's do this guys you
ready
yes yes okay it is greg and sarah from
kansas city missouri 86 thousand dollars
paid off in 28 months making 104 up to
114 and down to a still a pretty good 1
12. count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
3
[Music]
you love to hear it
i love it it's amazing it's really cool
too where you hear this this aha moment
this aha moment of like there has to be
something different
and i remember for me i was in my
mid-20s george and i had tons of debt i
think like 25 000 of debt of credit
cards you know uh personal line of
credit medical bills and i
picked up my phone to call my mom to ask
her to put money in my bank account and
it was that moment where i was like why
am i calling my mom why do i have to ask
for help as a 25 year old i wasn't
financially independent i wasn't
dependent independent at all
and it was just this moment of i have to
do something different this isn't
working but i was so normal it was just
like well that's all my friends just
credit cards it was just living beyond
my means and that was the moment that i
was like dave talks about this it's this
moment where you just say never again
never again i've got i don't know what
i'm gonna do but i'm not gonna do this
something has to change and i loved
hearing that in their story of that
moment of like we're gonna do something
different yeah and if you haven't
experienced that moment find one it's
probably coming for you soon yeah if it
hasn't already get you convicted and
become debt free like greg and sarah
what an inspiring story awesome hey more
of the ramsay show coming up
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm george
campbell joined today by christy wright
national best-selling author host of the
chris christie ride show and an
all-around just wonderful person christy
we had a great time last week at the
game plan live stream event it was all
about goals and
you you brought the house down talking
about prioritizing all the goals i
helped them just set good goals and you
were like okay we there's a lot going on
how do we actually do this and fit it
into our lives and you have been
passionate about goal setting goal
planning and a lot of the calls that we
get stem out of people's goals yeah and
it's interesting too because i think
that if you don't we say this all the
time we quote zig ziglar but if you
don't begin with the end in mind you end
up crossing someone else's finish line
he's the way zig ziglar says it is if
you aim for nothing you'll hit it every
time and so we want to help people be
intentional with their money or their
time and what's interesting is
obviously you need a plan for both and
so one of the things that we are always
so proud to put out as a company is the
2022 goal planner and this is a tool i
guess about four years ago we created
this tool and what i love about it
george is it's not just a calendar
because yes some people like paper
calendars but i thought what are the
things in my life that i use while i
read books to grow in personal
development i'll do bible studies to
journal and and i'll journal and reflect
i'll write down my goals and and have
to-do lists and so how can i pull all
those together and so that's what we did
and it sells all every year but this has
a monthly theme every month there's
content there's tools there's templates
there's journal questions there's a
month in review where you reflect on the
month before you set goals for the next
month and um so this really is a tool
that helps you achieve the goals that
you set there's even opportunity storage
throughout the year
to reflect on those goals and say hey do
those need to change the world's
changing your plans might change your
priorities might change and uh and so
this is a great tool to help you guys do
what you say you want to do reach the
goals that you want to set so
if you want to get your copy of the 2022
goal planner you can get that at
ramseysolutions.com and i'm telling you
go ahead and get it if you're thinking
about getting it for someone as a
christmas gift get it now last year it
sold out earlier than it ever has
normally it sells out
beginning of january
this year or last year rather it sold
out beginning of december but because
the turnaround time to reprint them we
did not order more because they we would
have come in right at the end of the
selling season in january because it's
dated for the next year uh so yeah they
sell out if you want your copy go to
ramsey solutions.com get your copy of
the goal planner and uh it's a great
christmas gift for someone that is a
planner wants to set their goals and
actually reach them i love it i want to
get one for my wife but you know she
works really pretty too if you're on
youtube they're really beautiful the
aesthetic i wanted to say that but i
felt like it was beyond my my pay grade
it really is gorgeous our designers
actually this is a custom uh art piece
that she created for this which is
pretty cool so it's one of a kind and uh
so yeah it's beautiful it's nice to to
carry around in addition to being
practical it is i mean it's got it's
impressive to say at least yeah i love
it well we've got rebecca on the line in
new york city rebecca welcome to the
ramsay show how can christy and i help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure let's go
i am in a transitional part of my life
i'm in the middle of a divorce
and
i have one option of staying here where
it's very expensive i have no idea where
i'm going to live because i can't afford
to buy anything
if i sell my business
i will be
able to pay off all of my debt
um i can move out of state to the state
i've always wanted to go
i have some down time to figure out my
next step i'd be able to get my daughter
through
the rest of high school
and help my aunt who is elderly
wow
and if i sell the business and move i'll
have i'll have the six to twelve months
eleven expenses i'll have twenty percent
to put down on a house that i can
actually afford
um and i just really want to know if you
guys thought i was crazy because i'm
just going on face that'll all fall into
place if i show the business and just
start all over
i'm really sorry you're going through
this rebecca i'm really sorry you're
going through this i i hear in your
voice what a hard time this is and this
is a big decision in the midst of a
really hard time
i do just want to echo back to you what
you said to us it sounds like to me
that you know this is right you feel
that this is right that this is what you
want to do not just from the financial
side this gives you so much more than
just the finances it gives you a fresh
start
and the one piece of encouragement i
want to give you and it's it's a it's a
loving encouragement but something i
want you to think through um you've
built this business
and you've built it to to be the level
that it's out where it's so successful
that in selling it you're gonna have a
good amount of money to do all those
things you just outlined for us
the thing that i want you to just think
about and maybe pray about journal about
reflect on
is you will experience a loss when you
sell this
an emotional loss
you'll sell it you'll have some income
that will be great but you built this
and this business is your baby in a way
as well you pour your heart into it you
didn't get this successful by accident
you've worked really hard you've been
really intentional so just know that
while this may be right and i just want
to affirm that i think i hear in your
voice you've you've this is what you
want to do and you have every right to
do it you've built this up to do what
you want to do and if this is the right
time to do that then absolutely that's
what you should do all the things that
that would afford you
awesome
i just want you to take a minute
to soak it in
to think about okay this is a season of
letting go of one thing so that you can
move into the next season of this fresh
start you described i just want you to
take a beat to reflect on this business
and and really think about that and
allow yourself to feel some of those sad
feelings that losing that now that
obviously is coming in a time when
you've got a lot of other um difficult
things you're going through
but just don't expect that you'll get a
check and it'll be easy because there's
a piece of your heart in that business
too and um and and i think to your point
i think it'll be worth it i think it's
right i think it's going to open up so
many doors for you
but just know if you feel a little sad
in the process that's normal that's okay
it's a part it's a it's a thing that you
love very much as well
um one thing i do want to offer you to
uh while you're on the phone rebecca is
because i don't know what this new start
is going to look like for you i don't
know if you're going to start a new
business wherever you move to and
whatever that looks like but i would
love to walk with you um in the next six
months so my online training and
coaching group it's called the business
boutique academy but it's open right now
it opened today we close on thursday
night and i would love to just um if
you'll stay on the line have kelly give
you a free membership as just my gift to
you where you could be in this community
of other business owners and just have
these people walk with you put their
arms around you love when you encourage
you brainstorm new ideas what does
business look like for you in this next
season with this fresh start we can
brainstorm with you we can help you come
up with your ideas and help you get
started in this new city and uh and new
season so if you'll stay on the line
i'll have kelly uh give you a membership
to my coaching group the business
boutique academy i'd love to walk with
you so sorry you're going through this
but i'm super proud of how hard you've
worked to get this business to where it
is so that it's going to be able to to
provide all that for you yeah that's
awesome wow thank you so much
you're so welcome rebecca what kind of
business is this
i own a dog boarding channel we have
training hoarding and grooming that's
awesome and where do you want to move to
from new york city
north carolina
good news i've heard there's dogs there
this is this sounds like it's going to
be a great fit for you as far as
restarting the business goes i mean
obviously you're going to have to find
client new clientele and location and
all that but it sounds like this is a
good business that you can replicate in
any city
yes it is and i want to take some down
time to maybe
slightly change the current business
model um
and i was going to take that down time
to just sort of figure it out you know
what i still want still want to work
with dogs i just
i'm a little burnt and i really want to
you know prioritize my time with my
daughter and my aunt right now who's 89
and needs help yeah
well the good news is you can do that
you have worked really hard to build
this up so that you can do that and that
seems think that's a really wise way to
approach this new season i love it
you're an incredible place financially
to be able to sell that have six to 12
months you're 20 down and get you and it
sounds like a house is a goal for you
which obviously very difficult to do in
new york city so it sounds like you're
going to check a lot of boxes off by
moving to new york to north carolina is
that right
yes i will that's awesome well i'm sorry
you're going through the divorce that's
not an easy thing to go through as as
good of a spot as you're in financially
emotionally you're going through it
right now so
let the timing be right for you
especially with the daughter and you
wanted to get her
you know through high school but this
move as far as business side goes i
think it's going to be a smooth
transition and you can really retool
this because you've created the margin
and the freedom to do that by doing such
a great job handling this business so
congratulations to you yeah thank you
thank you so much for your feedback i'm
really very grateful for it i really
respect your opinions and thank you well
you you stay on the line kelly will get
you taken care of with an academy
membership and actually kelly send her
also a copy of my devotional um living
true 40 days to get back to you
hopefully that will just be a word that
will encourage you as you're going
through this divorce that can help you
as well i love it i'm going to call that
the christie wright care package there
you go
starting now
well this has been a fun hour christy i
want to thank james childs our producer
kelly daniel associate producer and
phone screener i want to thank christy
wright my co-host and you america for
sticking around this show is all about
you and we appreciate you listening in
we'll be back
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio it's the ramsey show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life and your
money i'm ramsay personality george
campbell and i'm joined today by ramsay
personality christy wright we are taking
your calls this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five what do you
wanna talk about what is the burning
question on your mind what do you need
confirmation for a little bit of
guidance a little bit of wisdom that's
where christy comes in i'm here for
entertainment i'm just eye candy
well we are happy to take your calls and
we are kicking off this hour with
alessandra in mcallen texas welcome to
the ramsay show
hi good afternoon um so
uh i just want to say i'm like a huge
fan i listen to the show all the time
and if anything dave ramsey's voice kind
of suits my crying baby
babies i anger babies and dave calms
them
how can i know so i'm yeah i'm calling
because um my husband and i this past
year of um
i believe it was like this like right
after covert had hit like around march
of 2020 until last um this past november
right so it's going to be about a year
already um we paid up all of our debt
like throughout the pandemic like we
just went at it hard like i mean we got
rid of 47 000 worth of debt um
that was student loans that was um our
car
pretty much just student loans in our
car that was pretty much it but um we
tackled it we got rid of it so we've
been
breathing just a lot easier since then
it's been really great we had a baby our
pregnancy was awesome like we didn't
have to worry about money nothing like
we saved up just to pay the hospital
bills all of it was taken care of
now my husband just told me that he has
and i've always known this he's always
wanted to go to grad school and become
an engineer
and so i'm super supportive of his
decision
we were punching the numbers this past
weekend and now we have anxiety um we
currently make about we currently bring
home 5 400
every month um our
like our expenses are almost 3 000 right
and so the idea is if he goes back to
school i really want him to focus on
school it's a two-year graduate school
program it's going to cost us 20 grand
and i want him to stop working i would
be our sole provider and our bills are
about 3 thousand so
i mean what i make is three thousand
alone every month and our bills are
three thousand so it's like we're going
to be living like
being able to pay our bills and
everything but it's like
i don't i'm we're kind of nervous you
know and why do we do want him to stop
working and
see the problem is that do i
stop maybe putting into my 401k so we
can make a little more or
my dad has just offered to give us a
credit card um and that's just it's very
i don't like any of these options so far
i i want to call out one thing in your
question alessandra because yeah i think
this is interesting
the way that you set this up and i just
want to dig into this little bit
were very much i statements
i want him to stop working and i want to
be the sole provider and i want him to
focus on school what does he want in
relation to school
i i mean maybe he wants sustained i know
we should use i mean we're a team and
everything and i just um
i know he wants to stop working but i
also know that
for him it's hard to see me it's just
like this whole provider just because
he's like we have a new baby and i see
him now he's just still like
focused on giving us a better future
which is why i think he wants to go to
grad school so bad like i think
i just want to be as supportive as
possible what am i doing to be like sole
provider i love that you're willing to
be but you in your question you pointed
out that what you make is what your
expenses are and it would be tight it
would be tight and you have a baby it
would be tight
and there would be some discomfort there
so my question is instead of these
extremes of you're the sole provider
money is really tight he works full-time
what if there's a compromise where yes
you work
and he also works it might be part-time
or he extends the graduate program i
don't know if that's a possibility but
um you know i i'm in graduate school
right now taking one class at a time
it's gonna take me five years but that's
the time i can commit i know they're not
all the programs are not the same i
understand that but my question is there
are people that work during school all
the time maybe it's not full-time to
your point where it would really be that
would be exhausting but i could see him
working 10 or 20 hours a week and just
that amount of money that he would be
bringing in in a part-time job would
give you
a little bit of margin
where you're not so stressed because i'm
just trying to get you out of that
position where it's like yeah we're
going to do this and it's going to be
miserable when you don't have to be you
guys have done a great job you can do
this either at a slower pace or with him
working a little bit or both by the way
where you can enjoy the process he's
still focusing on school and you're
still super supportive but it's just not
these extremes george you know what i'm
saying like where it's like it's it's a
i think there's a lot more options here
to christie's point have you done all
the research you can as as far as what
are the right schools for this does the
education match the goals are there
cheaper options are there more flexible
options what is what is driving you to
this specific school
uh mostly because it's cheaper it's one
of the cheapest schools that we can find
in texas and we're gonna pay for it like
we're paying out of pocket our goal is
to 20 thousand dollars to save up 20
grand before he goes we're right now at
12 grand oh so we're almost there so
you're saying when you get to 20 you can
cashflow the whole thing but he still
has to stop working but you don't have
the
the payment for school there so you
could your expenses you know it might
get a little tighter but you may not
need all that margin because you're not
then saving for school
yeah like we're done saving like and
regularly like i want
what we really really want to like have
that 20 grand set aside and so it was
like the semester start we just paid in
full paid in full pain pool that was a
great work and be comfortable
um but again like i said like quickly
clean it out like a niche i don't know
just that margin of sleep do you have an
emergency fund in place
yeah we have fifteen thousand dollars
set aside great and i would not pause
investing i want you guys to keep doing
this you're not at a place where this is
some emergency fire you're soaking in
cash flow yeah no credit cards none of
that we can do this you you guys know
the plan you've done it you've done so
well you've done so well the only thing
i think that we want to point out is we
don't want you to make a decision that's
so extreme where you're just miserable
and so tight the next two and a half
years is there a way for you to still
reach the school goal and and have a
little bit of margin yeah can maybe he
can continue working part-time
maybe you can pick up some extra hours
to create a little bit of that breathing
room so that you guys aren't you know
have this anxiety looming in your life
when every every check is just so tight
but i think this is absolutely doable
you guys got this i think you just
needed a little bit of confirmation that
uh you need to make the right steps here
not going to debt no credit cards don't
pause investing you're so close you're
already at 12 000 you need 20 and you
have the margin in your budget to get
there really quickly and get him through
grad school the other thing that um may
just help is maybe you say maybe he
stops working right when classes start
and you give him two months to get into
the program the learning curve learning
how to be a student again there's some
learning but once he gets the rhythm
like okay these are the hours this is
the homework this is the then now i know
hey on saturdays i can take a full
part-time job or on these evenings once
he gets his his his bearings he probably
can take on some hours and that will
help but yeah maybe there's a period of
time where he gets gets used to being a
student again yeah and you guys have
that conversation get on the same page
no surprises set the expectations
communicate regularly and he'll get
through grad school in no time awesome
job
[Music]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work first go
to ziprecruiter.com
ken then create a free profile and let
their technology do the hard work by
finding and sending you jobs that are a
great fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell ramsey personality joined today
by christy wright
825-5225
call us with your questions about money
life whatever is on your mind andy is on
the line in atlanta georgia andy welcome
to the ramsay show
thank you very much i'm a huge fan and a
follower of dave's
steps
uh for many years since i
a while back quit my job to gain
ownership in the business and took like
a 75 pay cut for a while so wow the
envelope system got us through awesome
cool to hear how can we help today
well
so
i went through that period of time to
gain ownership in a business
i've been able to turn the business
around and grow it relatively
significantly
so i'm no longer at the 75 percent paid
level and
i've been a lifelong favor
we're debt-free have been for years
house has paid off
uh
we could technically retire
if we needed to i'm 54.
but anyway we're to a point where i mean
our kids college is all fun that i got
to in college and i'm wondering at what
point is it okay
to or how do you get over the guilt when
you want to buy yourself a toy i've
never done it i've always put the money
in the bank i've always saved it i've
always
been the responsible one but darn it i
want a mid-engine corvette
there we go
say it out loud andy so you guys have
been so diligent for so long that now
you're like i can't seem to let go of
this money even though i saved i worked
so hard it just feels frivolous i love
how andy said how do you get over the
guilt i was like what guilt andy i just
got there where where is the skills
coming i'm the spender andy the fact
that you said that shows that you're
just such a saver which is what's led to
your success today so well done yeah
well you know thank you what helps me is
is taking some of the emotion out of it
taking the guilt out and just looking at
hard numbers and we've got some
parameters to help you you know make a
wise decision here so what is your
annual income
well all right i'll say it varies but
it's going to be between 275 and 350.
wow fantastic and how much does this car
cost
uh
about 85 out the door
okay
and do you have any other vehicles right
now anything with a motor in it boats
any other toys yeah one other vehicle we
actually just
gave our senior in college our older car
for uh
for his great success in college so
we're down to one
uh
kia that we paid cash for wow what's
that kia worth
oh probably about 20 grand
okay
so if you got this 85 grand corvette
that leaves you with about 105 000
worth of cars and that's it nothing else
with motors in it
and you make up to 350 000 a year
yes
andy i it's an easy decision for me
now but now you know the answer the
answer is yes you can buy the car but
the real question is how do i get over
the guilt about buying this car well the
other thing is and i'm believing i went
over the numbers with my my wife because
we just i just did the profit sharing
for the business and
i mean that alone pays for the car but
i so i did this
with my wife but my life if you think
i'm a saver
you ought to see my wife she's a bigger
saver so well yeah our
she's on board but okay she's on board
our parameter is that we don't want more
than 50 of your income tied up and
things with motors in it because they go
down in value
and so sometimes it helps to look at
this from a give save spend perspective
if you want to make this a more wise
decision make you feel better about it
go ahead and give a portion of that
profit sharing and be generous with it
and then you'll feel a little more free
to spend some of it and you already have
plenty of savings it sounds like you
guys can retire early you've done so
well now is the time to enjoy this stuff
a lot of people they go through life and
they work so hard their fists are closed
they're just clenched working their
whole lives and you guys have earned
this this is not a frivolous purchase
now if you were calling me and you were
a 22 year old who had student loan debt
and said hey i want to buy an 85 000
corvette i'd smack him upside the head
but andy i want to give you a high five
and take a ride in that thing that's
right
here's the other thing andy and i if
you're like my husband and how he's
wired he's the saver in our relationship
and and he hates spending money like
even if we have the money even if we
budgeted we're on the same page it's
something we want we need whatever i
remember we moved in our house and we
wanted to get a tv for the bonus room
and he wanted to get this big
flat screen tv we absolutely had the
money we budged he still was like torn
up
but
after we got it he loved watching
football games on this tv i think you're
gonna love having it this is something
you want you've worked really hard your
whole life to save and be wise your debt
free your home is paid for you have an
incredible income
yes
yes you can enjoy some of it and that's
part of it so maybe for you because
you're such a saver andy maybe you start
to think anticipate the reward
anticipate man this could be so fun to
have and to your point george
george
george uh you have worked for it andy
you have worked for it you have earned
it and uh you should enjoy some of the
fruits of your labor some of the fruits
of your hard work way to go inspiring
stuff that is so cool it's so funny how
different people are wired differently
of the sabers and the spenders the
savers even if they have the money they
struggle to spend it
the spenders even if they have the
budget budget they struggle to save so
it's just it's in our wiring but hey
it's what it's what he values and he's
worked really hard for it so cool we
love to see it all right tony joins us
in los angeles california tony welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for having me sure
what's going on
well it's a relationship question i've
been with my um now fiance for about 11
years
uh off and on we broke up for two
and got back together three years ago
um we've met we're now engaged and so
now in the process of getting ready for
the wedding and everything
i come to find out that
asking questions about money
and i come to find out that he's living
paycheck to paycheck he has no money
saved
um and i just don't know if i should
continue in this relationship i'm i'm
really scared of
not being
in a stable relationship and
i i don't know that
i just don't know that if i can continue
i'm really
really scared now
tony i want to ask a question that's not
a money question
why are you getting married why are you
marrying him
i
do love
him um
but this really
it made me scared
of
like what our future is gonna be like
because
i mean i'm already older i'm already 44
he's 48 and
love doesn't pay bills
i'm sorry i sound really mean but
i just i don't i've already been married
once before
and i don't want to
i don't want to struggle
yeah
i don't blame you for that i'll tell you
in your question the thing that concerns
me yeah there's the how he handles money
to me that's secondary george um
it's the fact that y'all have been on
again off again for 11 years that's
always a red flag to me why are we off
why are we on why are we off and on and
on and off and i don't i don't know
about that to me i don't know about that
well it's only it's only happened one
time um we were together for close to
seven years and then we broke up for two
years
and then we got back together recently
and that's where we've been together now
for three years but why were you all
together for seven years and never got
engaged when you're in your what would
that be 30s
yeah and that's exactly why we broke up
was because i
found that there was no end goal and to
me if i'm going to be in a relationship
like we need to ultimately get married
i'm not going to just be your girlfriend
for the rest of our lives so then why'd
y'all get back together
because he had committed to me that that
was what our that was going to happen we
were going to get married every you know
he had made it seem like financially he
was doing better he was starting to earn
more money
and so i thought okay well
and you know he has a
he had a big temper and i saw a change
in him actually
fixing his anger issues
yeah um tony tony let me just tell you
what i'm hearing in this i'm hearing 50
000 red flags
anger money
non-committal
you can go to a counselor if you want to
i don't think you're ready to marry him
i don't think he's ready to marry you
maybe ever but certainly not right now
if he wanted to get his act together
maybe i'm a kind of person where i'm
like you've shown me who you are
you've shown me for the last 11 years
that's me but if you want to work out
talk to a counselor i definitely don't
think you're ready right now i got i got
red flags going up everywhere right now
on this one
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined by christy wright
christy before the break we took a call
from tony in los angeles and she just
got engaged after being with this man
for about 11 years off and on and she's
worried because he's not good with money
he's living paycheck to paycheck and
this is all coming out very recently
yeah and here's the other thing and it
was interesting as we dug into her
question and right as we were going into
the break she gave us some more
information that i'm like ah that's
gonna be a no but we didn't really get
to dig into it and she said his anger
issues and so that was
one major red flag on top of all the
other ones but here's the thing i think
i just want everyone to remember and
this is true for anyone in any situation
if you have a circumstance where you
feel like
this doesn't feel right
it's because
it's not right tony called us and she
already knew
that this is not a good idea now she's
calling with a money question it's
wrapped in a money question hey he's not
good with money we started digging
he has a commitment problem he has got
anger issues there's so many layers to
this
that are so bad and in my opinion anger
she's way worse than being bad at money
you can fix the money thing the anger
issue is majorly concerning and so i
just want to encourage people you
whether you're a person of faith or not
as a believer i believe that is the holy
spirit in us that guides us it's like
hey hey hey hey hey avoid that hey hey
it's to protect us even if you're not a
person of faith i think you would
acknowledge we have intuition whatever
you want to call it a conscience a
feeling i've got a feeling some doesn't
feel right you might not be able to put
words to it but i just want to encourage
people you listen to that feeling you
listen to that intuition you listen to
the holy spirit you listen to that
because when you have a feeling
something's not right it's because it's
not right and that's just um i i just
couldn't stop thinking about tony after
we went into the break of just what a
concerning situation that is that she's
in
and um and and just pay attention to
that pay attention to the red flags pay
attention that feeling uh it's there to
protect you yeah and you know there are
things like premarital counseling and
financial peace university which can be
great tools but at some point things may
be too drastically different and jarring
to to try to repair especially after
over a decade well if someone was just
calling and they just said hey my fiance
is not good with money
we discovered this in premarital
counseling for example we haven't talked
about money quite you know that much up
to this point we're engaged and turns
out he's bad with money that'd be like
hey
people can learn maybe they don't know
maybe they need to take class there's
lots of wonderful people that would be
wonderful spouses that just need
help learning that's what we help people
do is learn this skill
but on again off again for 11 years
wouldn't commit to being married after
seven years and
anger issues the angriest who's got me
george i'm not gonna lie the music
started coming in my ears and i was like
angry and i didn't have time to dig it
back just like no no
no
not right now for sure on the money side
but with the anger issues i'm like not
really ever not really ever you've shown
me who you are
um i just i just wanted to circle back
and remind people if you have that
feeling inside you that something's not
right it's because it's not right pay
attention to that feeling and tony has
that feeling you could hear it in her
voice when she called yeah i hope she
listens to it it's a hard conversation
to have to try to end something like
this after 11 years there's a little bit
of that sunk cost fallacy where you know
she's built her life with him she's 44
and he's 48 and you go it's too hard to
restart but i'm telling you tony it's
never too late and it's going to be
worth it because you're worth it it's
better than
the alternative which is committing to a
relationship that is
has some major problems at best and
scary at worst and um yeah i'd rather
start over then then sign up for a life
of that so i hope i hope she does yeah
tony to that intuition
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
ramsey to get the best deal rules and
restrictions apply
today's question comes from jennifer in
tennessee lately when i buy things
online i see that there's an option to
break the cost up in payments
rather than paying in full i'm not sure
if it's a good idea to take advantage of
these offers is doing this the same
thing as putting something on layaway at
the store
this is an interesting question i'll be
honest george i don't know i don't know
the terms around this i'm sure you do
this is fine print material this is your
specialty this got me riled up so you're
ready we just we just did a recent
episode of this on the fine print it's
called after pay affirm klarna should
you buy now pay later say that again you
lost me these are the names of companies
after pay affirm klarna these are the
names you see below the add to carter
should you buy now pay later and we dug
into this um and let me tell you
it's not good i can tell but that's not
good first of all their marketing is
hilarious because they say they want to
create financial freedom for their
customers by chaining them to payments
uh and here's the company clara here's
what they claim to retailers because
that's who their their target demo is
you'll spend forty five percent more if
you use it buy now pay later service on
your website wow so every retailer in
america is going absolutely you can be
on my website and we'll give you a cut
or we'll pay the fee whatever that looks
like
so
to your question jennifer
no it's not a good idea to quote take
advantage they are taking advantage of
you and so we tell people to budget save
up pay cash i know it can be tempting
when you've got a hundred dollars in the
cart and they say hey what if he just
paid 25 today free up that budget free
up the money in the budget way wiser no
this is payments this is debt and uh
it's even worse than layaway because you
get it now and so there's this element
of urgency that's just like well i
already got it yeah and i'll just be
stuck with the payments for another four
months yeah and so it just i want to
rally against this culture of
consumerism that says i want it now
prime now two hours now i don't care if
i don't have the money i want it now so
stay away from buy now pay later
services only pay for it if you can
afford it in cash with a debit card that
kind of thing the thing that i think is
just so important for people to remember
behind any of these whether it's credit
card points flyer miles rewards buy now
pay later break it up in payments guys
you just need to remember
these people
are not
trying to help you they're not your
friend they are not doing this out of
the goodness of their sweet little
hearts because they're just so generous
no they're doing it because there is
something in it for them which is
usually interest which is usually
spending more which is usually something
that helps them and hurts you they are
not trying to help you and so i just uh
it's good to remember that credit card
companies are not in these giant
buildings spending billions of dollars a
year on advertising because they're just
losing money on the deal here yeah
you're the one losing money you can go
check out that episode of the fine print
wherever you listen to podcast all right
let's go to the phones here we've got
william and dallas texas william welcome
to the ramsay show
hello thank you for um taking my call
sure how can we help
okay um i just changed jobs and um i'm
looking to go back to school and i'm
i've
got a question what should i
prioritize um what should i have as
as
my focus
well what what give me the why what's
the backstory there of why you're
changing jobs while you're going back to
school
um
well i was in landscaping for a long
time and i i kind of
i kind of don't like working out in the
heat in texas heat anymore and i want to
have a bigger impact than just
just working
and um
and wearing myself out
yeah i i totally get that here's what i
would love to to do for you william i
would love to um get you a pre-ordered
copy of ken coleman's new book from
paycheck to purpose because his very
first step in his path to doing work
that you love is to get clear and he
actually walks you through how to do
that he talks about this frequently on
his show the ken coleman show you can
tune into that every single weekday as
well between now and when your book
arrives he's got an assessment william
where you can take this assessment to
understand what are your greatest
talents your passions what is the impact
that you want to make specifically
there's lots of ways to make an impact
and so if you'll stay on the line what
i'll do is i'll have kelly get you set
up with ken coleman's assessment that
you can start now i'm pretty sure right
george you can take it today and get
your results and see what those areas
are for you to give you clarity in the
meantime and then when his book comes
out in just a few weeks you can read
that book you can listen to his show in
the meantime and he will walk you
through how to get clear because that's
one of those things that that needs more
time than we have today to be able to
dig into this with you but i think he's
going to help you discover what are you
really good at what are you excited
about and what results do you want to
create and when you know that
information you're getting clarity about
all the ways that you could live in that
all the different jobs you could do to
do that and that will show you what your
focus should be what you want to go to
school for and obviously getting
qualified as a step in his path as well
which you were talking about so stay on
the line we'll have kelly get you set up
william what are you going to school for
um chemical engineering very nice
big shift my man well that's awesome
yeah well we're cheering you on if
that's if that's your passion that's
what you want to be doing we can help
you get there ken's book is going to be
crucial along that journey we're
cheering you on man this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
psalm 104
enter his gates with thanksgiving and
his courts with praise give thanks to
him and praise his name
gk chesterton said i would maintain that
thanks are the highest form of thought
and that gratitude is happiness doubled
by wonder
love that doubled by wonder good quote
kevin joins us on the line in phoenix
arizona kevin welcome to the ramsay show
hi
um
so
my question is is uh
my wife is trying to launch her like
dream photography business um
and uh
and i want to be supportive and help her
but um
i know that i'm overwhelming a lot of
the time like i throw too much at her to
try and help her get the business out
around and i just wanted to know if you
had any advice on what i can do to be
more supportive and helpful without
being as overwhelming well i love that
you're asking kevin that is just so cool
it shows you are supportive by the fact
that you're even asking this question so
well done uh tell me a little bit about
your wife and tell me a little bit about
what you mean by overwhelming are you
asking lots of questions how will this
work how will you pay taxes is it that
kind of stuff or what what's
overwhelming her
so i've ran a photo business in the past
so like i kind of like realized what i
did wrong in the past and i'm trying to
just tell her like hey where is your
logo design uh what are your business
plan what is your you know i just like
throw all of this at her i think at once
and it just kind of overwhelms her
so i'm just
uh you know and she's just trying to
start um this business because uh we're
expecting our first baby
um and she really wants to kind of work
from home more yeah
and work on her own schedule and i
really want that to happen so um
yeah well that's well that's awesome
congratulations on your little one
tell me a little bit about your wife
what's her personality style like why
does she want to do photography give me
some of the back story there because i
think that'll help me maybe advise you
on how to support her because you know
different people are motivated by
different things so tell me a little bit
about her what's her personality like
um she's very outgoing she loves helping
people
she's very um
i don't know when when we first started
dating the first thing i noticed like
she lights up a room kind of like and
really kind of people gravitate towards
her and uh and they really like being
around her is she creative that's
helpful
yeah super creative yeah she comes up
with solutions all the time that i never
think of i love that okay i want to give
you some advice that i heard
from a friend forever ago okay kevin and
this has been george this is some of my
favorite advice when it comes to people
that are married with any relationship
but specifically in couples because we
often tend to marry someone that's our
opposite
um you've got a saver you've got a
spender you know in a relationship well
the way that this person outlined this
advice to me that i want to give to you
kevin is in most relationships you have
a
wow person
and a how person
the wow person is typically the creative
wow this is amazing wow isn't this
awesome wow i have a bunch of new ideas
wow i'm so you know all these creative
things the how person is the
more logical the planner the well how
will this work and how much money will
it cost and how will you do your logo
and how will you market yourself and how
will you find the time and all the how
questions
so here's the here's the tough part when
you're a wow person and your how person
starts asking all the how ideas which
are valid it feels like they're raining
on your parade it does feel overwhelming
i have not thought through this details
details this is matt wright right he has
100 questions from him like i'll figure
that out later right don't rain on my
pronate
so here's the rule here's the advice
that this person gave me kevin that i
think might help you the advice is this
when the wow person comes home with a
new wow idea which is every day
then the how person is not allowed to
ask any how questions for 24 hours okay
now this can be hard for you kevin but
you're not allowed to know how questions
whatsoever
if the wow person
in this case your wife is still thinking
of that same idea the next day 24 hours
later which is highly unlikely because
they probably have 400 new ideas but if
they are
this idea really means something to them
and then you can gradually
slowly
in a sensitive way start asking your how
questions
so it sounds like your wife has been
asking about has been talking about this
for a while a while so what i would
encourage you to do is just space out
your how questions the how will this
work how the following instead ask more
creative questions just in the beginning
to show your support speak her language
say how do you visualize this
what are you most excited about
what do you think will be your favorite
part
what type of pictures do you want to
take do you want to do newborns or like
wedding photos
you know
some of those more creative to engage
her creative mind and when you start
speaking her language i think she will
light up i think she will start rattling
off oh my gosh i thought about doing
this and this and this and so on and you
can sprinkle in somehow once you can
sprinkle in like well what about okay
let's think about this how much money do
you think we need to get the camera that
you really want to be able to execute on
all those fun ideas if you just space it
out where you're speaking some of her
language it's not just your language i
think that will show her that you are
supportive it will get her excited and
the hard part kevin is for you to
discern
when to give advice
because you've done this before and you
should give advice and your vice's
advice is valuable
but when to maybe just bite your tongue
on that one when to let her figure that
one out when maybe she's not ready or
doesn't want to hear it you know what i
mean because there is a creative process
where there's some of it that she wants
to figure out herself and that's okay
and so i think for you it's speaking her
language asking lots of open-ended
creative based questions and uh and
maybe sprinkling in those how questions
throughout and i think that will show
her support i would love to also while
we've got you um
on the phone kevin if you would stay on
the line i would love to give your wife
a membership to my business boutique
academy she um she can my coaching group
is open this week for new members today
through thursday only and i will be
walking with this next group for the
next six months where i do training and
coaching every single month so if you'll
stay on the line i'll have kelly give
your wife a membership she can join my
coaching group i would love to walk with
her help her answer her questions and uh
and help her get that business idea off
the ground so if you'll stay on the line
i'll have kevin kip kelly words are hard
today uh kelly give you that as well i
love that kevin i see a lot of myself
sure she'll love it yeah that's awesome
i see a lot of myself and you kevin i'm
that i'm that guy you're the how i'm and
i'm helpful i'm just like well i'm being
so helpful aren't i sure matt wright is
being helpful yeah what i found when my
wife wanted to start doing clay earrings
during the the you know quarantine okay
and i was like oh i can help you make a
lobo logo and i can even make a website
and i realized that she needed more
ownership yeah and it kind of got less
fun the more i got involved so sometimes
i had to learn to just step back and go
this needs to be her thing yes and
unsolicited help is rarely helpful yeah
yeah that's what i found so kevin are
you running into that a lot
yeah it's something that like uh yeah
like i'll like she'll ask me a question
and then i'll just throw a bunch at her
and i can see it in her face where she's
just kind of like
oh
and like
you know i didn't think about that and
it kind of and like i don't mean to be
downer i'm trying to like
help her like like
get an idea of what it's going to take
but i some and sometimes i see it and
i'm like god i should stop talking but i
can't
kevin i can relate this is marriage i
can relate i love that but i i totally
get that that you feel this this urge to
go well what about this and and she
deflates her and you go well i'm not
being a pessimist i'm being a realist
yeah this is what it's going to take to
get the business off the ground but a
lot of times that can stifle the
progress that she's making that she's
feeling towards this and i think once
she owns it she'll bring you in
because she's going to find the things
that she isn't good at or doesn't want
to do and say hey kevin can you help me
with this i really am not great at logos
and design i'd love your brain on this
yeah and then it's a partnership instead
of this hey do you think about this it's
like a devil on the shoulder yeah well
and the other thing kevin is it'd be
good for you to
to weed through of all your advice read
through what is necessary that she
really needs to know and you really are
helping like hey you really need to have
a cancellation policy because if not
people are going to cancel last minute
some i'm making this up but whatever you
really feel are like she's got to know
this and what are the things that you
did it that way but she doesn't have to
do it that way they're optional you
could even offer that way like well hey
i did it like this when i did it but i
don't think you have to i think you
could do it this different way or what
do you think you can turn it back on her
and ask questions like hey what do you
think so um i think maybe even just
weeding through that what does she need
to know and what is kind of like you did
it that way but you don't have to yeah
and even let her fail a little bit yeah
i think that's gonna actually motivate
her more to go okay i gotta figure this
out on my own and she'll bring you into
it but i think that's so awesome to have
a supportive husband like that way to go
who's eager to help instead of going oh
i don't care yes oh my gosh the fact
that you're calling and asking just
shows how supportive you are great job i
love it hey it's been a fun show christy
my thanks to producer james childs
associate producer and phone screener
kelly daniel my co-host christy wright
you america it's been a good time and
we'll be back with you before you know
it until then spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you